[Musique]
respecter le suffrage universel
respecter la démocratie respecter la
république c'est entendre les français
les comprendre mais surtout c'est agir
la proximité du citoyen il ya un délit
qui est commis même une incivilité pour
pas dire un délit il faut que ce soient
sanctionnés et que le citoyen le voir je
pense qu'il faudrait réellement aider
les petits ménages et des légendes et et
à ressortir la tête de l'eau de façon à
ce que la france or eux démarrent les
valeurs républicaines c'est les droits
et des devoirs
il faut définir à les valeurs
républicaines pour chaque français et
les appliquer
appliquer la loi comme elle se doit et
faire comprendre aux personnes qui
veulent la nationalité française qu'ils
ont des devoirs et qu'ils ont des droits
et les deux étant nécessaire et je pense
que c'est comme ça qu'on évitera un
racisme sous jacent ans j'aime la
liberté profondément parce que pour moi
ce pays et a donc ouverte et ça paye
démocratie qui n'est pas question une
seconde quand l'espace est autre chose
que la demande patients la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité
tout est dit à partir de là et
l'expérience pour que chaque fois que
dans l'histoire nous avons mis en cause
ses principes ses valeurs ça s'est très
très mal passé
[Musique]
il faut d'abord et c'est l'essentiel
restaurer l'autorité de l'état et que
chacun ait conscience que la loi
républicaine s'applique à tous sans
exception qu on ne peut pas y échapper
je le suppose une vraie prise de
conscience au niveau le plus élevé de
l'état
d'où la création du conseil de sécurité
intérieure sous la présidence du
président de la république que j'ai
proposé d'où la création d'un ministère
de la sécurité publique chargée de
coordonner l'ensemble des moyens de poly
l'ordre d' enquêtes dont disposent les
français d'où également la création de
groupements d'intervention susceptibles
au delà des moyens généralement
insuffisant de la police ou de la
gendarmerie auxquels je rends hommage
pour leur qualité naturellement leur
courage et mais qui pondent éradiquée
dans un certain nombre de quartiers ou
de zone des systèmes mafieux qui se sont
mis en place à partir de la drogue de la
prostitution du trafic d'armes à partir
aussi de l'immigration clandestine et
sur lesquelles se développe la violence
et parfois la criminalité donc un
ensemble de mesures qui sont humaines
mais qui ont pour objectif de faire
respecter l'ordre et la loi
et puis deuxièmement il nous faut une
justice de proximité que je souhaite
mettre en oeuvre immédiatement qui
permettent de sanctionner tout délit de
façon à ce qu'il n'y ait plus d'impunité
d'abord parce que c'est légitime et
ensuite parce que c'est le seul moyen de
redonner un certain nombre de
jean de jeunes notamment mais pas
seulement des repères qui petit à petit
se sont effacées on ne sait plus ce que
l'on peut faire ou ne pas faire ce qui
est bien et ce qui est mal il faut
rétablir des repères savoir quelles sont
les limites que l'on ne peut pas
dépasser sans être sanctionné et enfin
il nous faut lorsqu'il s'agit de
multirécidiviste que nous connaissons
bien et qu'on retrouve 24 heures après
leur arrestation sur les lieux mêmes de
leur exploit si j'ose dire il faut les
mettre
chouette en prison quand ils sont
majeurs soit dans des centres mais des
centres fermés
lorsqu'ils sont mineurs de façon à
éviter qu'ils ne continuent à donner
l'exemple et l'impulsion à la violence
mais deuxièmement également qu'il puisse
être réinsérés par l'éducation réinsérer
dans la société
[Musique]